now that a suspect is in custody for the
death of journalist jeff german how long
might it take to actually prosecute that
case well the answer is a very long time
as the eight news now investigators
discovered it's really not unusual for
murder case to drag on for three four
five years maybe longer the pandemic
contributed to a backlog felt throughout
the criminal justice system too george
knapp has our story
there's not one reason why she she was
killed there's not in the heat of the
summer 1994 81 year old aydah priolo was
stuffed into the trunk of her car and
left to die 25 years later cold case
detectives identified the suspect
christopher mack priolo's family hoped
for swift justice that's part of the
justice system game in nevada
is putting it off putting it off putting
it off it's not about the victim we get
ready emotionally and then we're slammed
back down again hurry up and wait after
three and a half years of delays and
continuances defendant mack took a plea
and will be sentenced soon long delays
and murder cases are common
and the clark county jail is full of
examples what we're dealing with is
folks that have been here and been here
for an extended period of time during a
tour of the jail with assistant sheriff
andy walsh we learned the place holds
more than 400 inmates charged with
murder approximately 30 of them have
been there for five years or longer
awaiting trial dozens of others are out
on bail as of today we have 59 murderers
on electronic monitoring
59 people wearing an ankle bracelet out
when the public back to work back with
their families who are charging murders
why would accused killers be released on
bail in general murder suspects do not
commit more murders if they get bail the
same is not true for say armed robbers
during our tour a rarity a murder
suspect out on bail was returned to jail
because he'd removed his ankle monitor
managing the jail population is both an
art and a science and was severely
tested by the pandemic local courts
essentially shut down during the worst
of covid creating a massive backlog and
criminal prosecutions those effects were
felt immediately at the jail fortunately
overall crime numbers plummeted during
the pandemic because fewer tourists came
to town and got into trouble though
murders and domestic violence cases
spiked metro has purposely maintained a
vacancy rate at the jail which allowed
them flexibility during covid to protect
both inmates and the jail staff we have
to even
sort of do what we can to keep the
inmate population that needed to stay
here safe and some folks that maybe
didn't need to be here that there was an
alternative way for us to get them out
we did that and now we're still hovering
in that 30 35 percent vacancy factor the
covet factor was far more evidence in
the courts trials were simply untenable
for more than a year which meant murder
cases and other serious crimes stacked
up by the fall of last year chief judge
linda bell described the backlog as
significant close to six thousand trials
waiting to commence two thousand more
than before covet hit in january an
edict was issued to all judges and
lawyers to get busy judges were told to
initiate at least 10 trials per category
including murder cases and lawyers were
warned to meet deadlines and avoid
continuances the prediction was it would
take 18 months to get caught up it
didn't new chief judge jerry weiss says
the courthouse has been jamming so we
had a 75 percent closure rate
in 21 our closure weight went up to 95
percent
and so far in 22 our closure rate's at
about 122 percent
which means to me that we are
substantially getting back into the
cases that have been aging over time you
do this did you commit this murder
murder cases including the pending
prosecution of a public official charged
with the stabbing death of journalist
jeff gearman won't be hindered because
of covid but still could take years to
complete whis says judges assigned to
homicide cases tend to be more lenient
with both prosecutors and defense
attorneys because the stakes are so high
d.a steve wolfson says that when a
possible death sentence is on the table
it's better to do it right than to do it
fast so that verdicts are not reversed
during inevitable appeals murder cases
are going to take longer because there's
so much at stake
and and rightfully so the defense
lawyers have a job to do they need to
investigate their cases but at the end
of the day we get justice
that was george knapp reporting now
district attorney wolfson went on to say
that earlier this year his prosecutors
won six homicide verdicts in just a two
week period